write the first four non-zero terms of
the maclaurin series for e to the x use
the maclaurin series for e to the x to
write the third degree taylor polynomial
for
g to the x is equal to e to the x times
f of x about x equals 0.
so maclaurin series if that looks
familiar to you watch the videos on khan
academy and maclaurin series i'll give a
little bit of a primer here if we're
taking the maclaurin series of f of x
that's going to be equal to
f of 0 we could view it as f of 0 times
x to the 0 over 0 factorial if you
assume 0 factorial is equal to 1 and
then plus
f
prime
of 0 times x to the first over 1
factorial
plus f prime prime the second derivative
evaluated at zero
times x squared
over two factorial i think you see the
pattern here plus
f
prime prime prime the third derivative
evaluated at zero of x to the third
power over three factorial i think you
see where this is going and of course
this first one x to the zero over zero
factorial that's just one so often times
it'll just be written f of zero and this
term 1 factorial is just 1. so often
times you'll just see it written as f
prime of 0 times x so on and so forth so
and actually let me just write
approximately right over there
and so
let's do it for e to the x so e to the x
is approximately equal to what's going
to be e to the 0 which is 1
plus
you might already know that
f
f of x if f of x is equal to e to the x
then f prime of x is also equal to e to
the x that's one of the magical things
about e to the x the derivative the the
slope of the tangent line at any point
is well equal to the value is equal to
the x value there and if you take the
third derivative
or second derivative it's also you can
take as many derivatives as you want you
still get e to the x that's one of the
special things about e so the first
derivative evaluated 0 well that's still
e to the 0 power times x to the first so
plus
x
and then we have the second derivative
evaluated at 0. well that's still 1 so
it's going to be times or so it's 1
times x squared over 2 factorial so we
could say plus
x squared over 2
plus x squared over 2 2 factorial is
just 2 times 1 and then plus once again
the third derivative evaluated 0 that's
just e to the x a value of 0 which is e
to the 0 which is 1. so x to the third
over 3 factorial so plus
x to the third
over 3 factorial we could write it as 3
factorial or that's 3 times 2 times 1
that's equal to 6. and then we keep
going so we just wrote the first
four non-zero terms of the maclaurin
series for e to the x that's one two
three four non-zero terms
now we wanna use so let me just
underline that that's part of what
they're asking us to do
then they say
use the maclaurin series for e to the x
to write the third degree taylor
polynomial for g of x which is equal to
the product of e to the x and f of x so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write our original f of x let's write
down the first few terms of it and then
what we can do is think about well how
can we multiply those two polynomials
and we just have to know enough about
the multiplication of those two
polynomials to just get us our our our
our terms that are no higher than third
degree
so f of x is approximately equal to
let's see it's x i have a bad memory it
is x minus three halves x squared
x
minus three has x squared
and then
plus three x to the third power
plus three x to the third power plus and
actually you could say minus if you like
because then it's going to be you're
going to have it's plus minus plus minus
however you want to do it and that's
enough and why do i feel confident that
it's enough well we only want we're only
we only want to write the third degree
taylor polynomial so if we multiply
these and we involve terms that are
higher than third degree well we're
going to we're that's going to give us
the height the the the terms in our
polynomial that are higher than third
degree
so let's just think about it what's
going to be the product so e to the x
e to the x times f of x
that's going to be approximately equal
to
well let's see we are going to multiply
this infinite polynomial times this
infinite polynomial
and that might seem intimidating to you
at first but what you could do is you
could go for each of these terms
start multiplying it times each of these
terms out here essentially you know when
you're multiplying polynomials you're
just repeatedly doing the distributive
property so you take this and distribute
it onto that but we should only worry
about the terms up to third degree
because anything beyond that well that's
going to be that's going to add up to a
higher than third degree term so x times
1 is x
x times x squared
or sorry x times x is x squared so plus
x squared
x times x squared over 2 is x to the x
to the third over 2. so i'll just write
plus
one half
x to the third power and i'm going to
stop there because if i do x times that
that's going to be a fourth degree term
and i don't want to worry about that we
are writing the third degree taylor
polynomial so x so that's x x squared x
to the third over 2.
so now let's distribute the negative
three halves x squared
and i'll use another another color here
just to help explain it a little bit so
if you multiply that times one
that's going to be
minus 3 halves
x squared i'm just going to a second
line here so i can line things up and
add them nicely and then this times
this is negative 3 halves x to the third
negative three has x to the third and
once again i'm gonna stop there if i
multiply these two i'm gonna get a
fourth degree term and i don't care
about the four degree terms
and then
let's do let's worry about this guy and
so let's start distributing so if i
multiply it times this 1 i'm going to
get 3x to the third power 3x to the
third power and i'm going to stop there
because then if i start multiplying it
times that guy that's going to be a
fourth degree term and then a fifth
degree term and then a sixth degree term
which i don't need to worry about so
these are all of the pieces that are
going to make up that third degree
polynomial and so what is that going to
be equal to
what is that going to be equal to this
is a little bit
this was a little bit of you know
getting your math intuition for
multiplying infinite polynomials let's
see you're going to have x
and then you're going to have this is 1x
squared minus one and a half x squared
so that's going to be negative one half
x squared and let's see
here you have plus one half minus one
and a half which would give you negative
two
and then plus three
plus oh no sorry one half minus one and
a half
which would be negative 1 plus 3 is
positive 2 plus 2
x to the third power so we could say e
to the x
times f of x the third degree taylor
polynomial for this
is
x minus one half x squared plus two x to
the third power and we
are
done so this was a little bit tricky
you had to appreciate how to but it's
not calculus it's a little bit of just
algebra i'm just appreciating only the
third degree i don't have to distribute
this times an infinite number of terms
and because at first you might say well
that's that's super hard how do i
multiply two infinite polynomials the
key is we only worry about the third
degree up to the third degree